der bär mutter transplantation seltsame
geschäftsidee und ekel chefs das sind
drei der fünf themen heute in den kriegs
und ob halb news zehn freiwillige für
eine gebärmutter transplantation werden
besucht und zwar von ärzten des queen
charlotte chelsea krankenhauses in
london
sie wollen es frauen ermöglichen kinder
zu gebären wenn diese keine oder eine
nicht funktionstüchtige gebärmutter
haben die voraussetzungen um probanden
zu werden sind folgende 25 bis 28 jahre
alt gesunde eierstöcke eigene eizellen
und so weiter nochmal zur erklärung den
probanden soll keine gebärmutter
entnommen sondern eine eingepflanzt
werden
ein ganzes jahr nach der transplantation
müssen die frauen noch medikamentös
behandelt werden
das heißt mit der transplantation allein
ist es noch lange nicht getan
die allererste gebärmutter
transplantation ging vor 15 jahren
schief die zweite verlief auch nicht
besonders erfolgreich nach sechs wochen
brachte die schwangerschaft ab eine
derartige transplantation ist also ein
unbekanntes risiko noch das den frauen
nach einer geglückten schwangerschaft
die gebärmutter wieder entnommen werden
soll
senkt das risiko wohl auch nicht gerade
aktuell bemüht sich die vom chirurgen
gegründete organisation und james blunt
uk gelder zu sammeln um das ganze
vorhaben finanzieren zu können
das budget müsste mehr als 600.000 euro
betragen nach einer forschungsarbeit kam
wissenschaftler auf eine etwas seltsame
geschäftsidee sie wollen kleine haus
schweine züchten und dann verkaufen
gezüchtet werden sollen die kleinen
tiere aber nicht auf natürliche art und
weise sondern mit hilfe einer gen
behandlung die ursprüngliche arbeit die
beschäftigte sich mit krankheiten die
uns menschen betreffen könnten
aber nach den versuchen mit den tieren
dachten sich die forscher wohl was nun
und da fiel ihm diese nennen wir es mal
schweinische idee ein sie setzten die
wachstumspläne der schweine außer
gefecht und erhielten somit auch ganz
simple art und weise ganz kleine
schweinchen die scheinbar der neue
verkaufsschlager werden sollen wenn sich
so ein schwein zulegen möchte
insofern das alles wirklich endgültig
passiert schon in der niedrigsten
preisstufe gute 1600 dollar hinblättern
müssen
das ist den chinesischen forschern des
hanson international biotech leaders
summit bgi noch nicht genug sobald sich
das ganze etabliert habe wäre der
nächste schritt merkmale wie farbe oder
ähnliches die sollen dann individuell
konfigurierbar sein also konfigurierbare
haustiere
naja klingt ehrlich nach einer
herrlichen plattform für kritiker und
ich finde auch das ist eine ziemliche
gerechtfertigte plattform für kritiker
nicht der chicxulub metroid sondern
heiße lava rottete die dinosaurier aus
forscher der university of california in
berkeley gaben dem meteoriten jetzt ein
alibi zumindest ein teil alibi für das
zu grunde gehen der dinosaurier sei
nämlich nicht er ganz alleine
verantwortlich den experten zufolge
hätten mehrere faktoren dazu beigetragen
sie berichteten darüber im fachmagazin
science neben dem einschlag habe zu der
zeit starker vulkanismus gewaltige
schäden angerichtet etliche vulkane
seien damals ausgebrochen und hätten
ihre heißen lava gesteine durch die
lüfte geschossen das herzstück des
vulkanismus liegt im raum indien
ausgelost wer ausgelöst worden wären
diese lava ausbrüche allerdings von
niemand geringerem als eben dem
meteoriten
das heißt ein ereignis auf der anderen
seite der weltkugel löste ein anderes
auf der anderen seite der weltkugel aus
zwischen den beiden orten legen nämlich
rund 15.000 kilometer zitat aufgrund
unserer datierung der lava können wir
ziemlich sicher sein dass der
vulkanismus und der einschlag innerhalb
der 50.000 jahre vor dem aussterben
stattfand so dass die trennung zwischen
den beiden mechanismen künstlich wirkt
zitat ende das sagte paul renner von der
university of california in berkeley
sowohl der meteoriteneinschlag als auch
der heftige vulkanismus in ihnen sind
belegte fakten
der einschlag des meteoriten ist
schließlich auch kaum zu übersehen auf
der mexikanischen halbinsel yucatan
findet man den weltberühmten chicxulub
krater und indien
liegt immer da liegen immer noch einige
riesige lava gesteinsbrocken herum
gesteinsbrocken ist gut gesagt er berger
hält bis zu 3000 meter in die höhe
nicht 3000 sondern 900 meter hoch aber
immerhin könnt ihr mich eine welle
werden die jede menge verwüsten würde im
fachmagazin zahlen etwas schreiben
forscher über ein naturereignis das
schon lange der vergangenheit angehört
aber durchaus noch mal so passieren kann
und zwar schlimmer vor 73.000 jahren
geschah auf der insel fogo folgendes
teile des vulkans pico do fogo brachen
zusammen und glitten ins meer ein
massiver stein rutscht gute 160
kubikkilometer sind damals ins wasser
gestürzt anhand von gesteins kunden auf
einer in der nähe liegenden insel
konnten experten unfassbares berechnen
die felsen gehören nämlich nicht zu der
insel wo sie gefunden wurden
eine mehr als 170 meter hohe welle oder
wellen könnten das ausgelöst haben das
was damals passiert ist könnte uns noch
einmal in einer ganz anderen
größenordnung erwarten geologen
beobachten den vulkan kumpel wk mit
wachsamen augen wenn dort ein erdrutsch
in bewegung kommt könnte das eine 900
meter hohe welle auslösen und dort das
ist auf dem kanal und die höhe dieser
welle würde nach südeuropa immer noch
zehn meter betragen
und ja das könnte dann für alle leute
die am an der küste leben ziemlich
gefährlich werden kommen wir zu den ekel
chefs verändern sich menschen wenn sie
karriere machen
die professorin für
persönlichkeitspsychologie jule specht
sagt nein
der mensch verändere sich nicht aufgrund
einer höheren karrierestufen ihre these
stellte sie mit hilfe der zahlen des
deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung diw auf das diw 60
seit rund 30 jahren mit rund 30.000
menschen zum thema arbeit und leben
auseinander zitat ich hatte angenommen
dass sich die menschen deutlich
verändern wenn sie führungsverantwortung
übernehmen so jule specht ihrer annahme
bestätigte sich aber nicht die
persönlichkeit habe sich zwar verändert
es kamen keine merkmale hinzu die schon
zuvor bestehenden merkmale entwickelten
sich lediglich deutlicher diese
entwicklung wird von den meisten als
negativ ausgelegt zitat das was die
mitarbeitenden als veränderung der
persönlichkeit empfinden ist meist nur
das ausfüllen einer anderen rolle
das berichtet die coaching annette
hillebrandt hillebrand macht neid die
skis und ähnliches sind also die
eigentlichen ursachen für die
vermeintliche veränderung der
aufgestiegenen kolleginnen und kollegen
diese frage darf sich jetzt mal jeder
selbst beantworten mehr zu einer
wirklich kuriosen transplantation
übrigens erfahrt ihr im video hier oben
unter dem zur app und zum block kommt er
auch über das sie einfach draufklicken
und dem finger oder mit der maus je
nachdem an welchem endgerät ihr seid und
ja wie sehen eure erfahrungen zum thema
apple chefs aus habt ihr schon
veränderung mitbekommen bei freunden
kumpels und so weiter und so fort hat
sich jemand in eurem umfeld verändert
nachdem sie oder er befördert wurde also
zum beispiel klassensprecher wurde oder
eine arbeitskreis geleitet hat oder eben
im job chef geworden ist schreibt uns in
die kommentare und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran